what's the difference in a in the
mindset of like you hang out with
billionaires and 100 millionaires what's
the difference in mindset of how those
guys made their money and somebody like
me that that that's not there yet you
know like what what's the difference
I mean greed probably you know like just
yeah I mean in order to get to a billion
dollars you have to like I mean there's
a few factors like unless you like
hit the lottery or some [__] like you
have to really
well yeah you have to be super shrewd
you have to really [__] like want
like infinite amounts of money you have
to because I mean most people they make
like a couple hundred million bucks like
I got you know two 300 million I got
enough like I don't need to make no more
money I don't need to work like I got
more than I can spend you know what I
mean like you have to really like want
money to become like a billionaire and a
billionaire multiple times over like a
lot of these guys because to me it's
like when I hit a billion two billion
I'm out like I'm never gonna work
another [__] day of my life like I'm
not gonna do anything that I don't want
to do for money ever like ever again I'm
not gonna [__] take meetings I'm not
gonna [__] you know like Network I'm
not gonna [__] do [__] nothing like
I'm just gonna live my life and do
whatever the [__] I want which is
similar to How I Live Now but like
occasionally I take meanings right none
of those
um but these guys man like they just
have a different mindset it's like they
just want more and more and more and I
think it's true of like money [__]
Power there's like a few things with the
like black holes where like if that's
your focus and that's what you want like
you're gonna to just go down that road
there's no end to it much like what you
said about the only fans like [__] if
I'm making fifty thousand I want 70. you
know like I want to like it and uh I had
you were really speaking Scott's
language on on that you know because
it's like because it's not hard work
because there's a lot of people that
work 18-hour days and they grind it out
it's like there's got to be a different
like well okay oh you're talking about
in that sense so so you're trying well I
mean I don't I don't know anything about
you I don't know what you do but if
you're saying like compared to a normal
guy what's the difference yeah a normal
guy is focused on basic needs met a
normal guy is like oh I want this
[__] badass motorcycle like they're
thinking like small ball they're
thinking like okay what do I got to do
to get this motorcycle like when you
when I look at business I'm like how can
I make the most amount of money in the
least amount of time possible like like
my goal is to make money I'm not there
to [__] enjoy my job I'm not finding
something that I like to do I want to
make the most money in the shortest
period of time possible and then Focus
the rest of my life on doing the [__] I
want to do and not have to [__]
answering anybody not to take [__] from
anybody that's my gold money so I look
at it differently you know I've got
friends that are like you know regular
blue blue collar guys and they like you
know they're like okay like I want to
open this gym because I like working out
and I'm just like that's not scalable
like well you know what you're trying to
do like this guy want to build like
small houses or like you know do I'm
just like the [__] you're trying to do
is not scalable like you want to focus
on a business that you can franchise you
can scale like something that you can
like have a home run but you can also
make like good money you know it's like
you want to have like a bunch of sticks
in the fire you want to have that home
run possibility you want to have the
sure money like I just look at it much
more analytical you know and a lot of
these people are you know focused on
like putting food on the table and like
you know it's just a different thought
process you know and like also you have
to have like a strong like ability to
take risk like a lot of people are not
nearly [__] like
capable of taking the kind of risk that
a lot of these billionaires take I know
billionaires that go broke and it
doesn't surprise me like it surprised a
lot of people but it doesn't surprise me
because in order to have that mentality
of like I want more and more and more
more you have to constantly be
overreaching so it's like for these guys
you know like Andy Beale I mean I think
the guy lost like four billion dollars
shorting Tesla or some [__] you know
what I mean like and I've seen guys like
you know and he was almost like
considering going all the way and if he
would have gone all the way I think he
might have gone broke and so it's like
to me like once you have a billion
dollars you should literally never go
broke like you should okay go gamble
with a hundred million like you know you
want to make more money fine like you
know take a piece and just like you know
risk that but like these guys will risk
it all you know and some sometimes
that's why they got what they got is
because they're willing to [__] risk
it all like a buddy of mine he was worth
500 million bucks I'm talking on the
phone I'm like just like he had like
almost all of his money in this hedge
fund you know and was like and he was
running the hedge fund and he was like
taking a lot of risk to Natural Gas
Trader and I'm just like bro like stop
like you're getting a 30 percent free
roll on everybody's money that's in the
funds you still have [__] upside you
know like what's the difference in your
life quality if you go from 500 million
to a billion not much now you can own
the yacht or maybe have a bigger yacht
you know but if you rent it you're still
on the same [__] yacht the same
amount of time like your lifestyle
doesn't really change that much but if
you draw you cut in half or you lose you
know 400 million your life changes a
little bit it's like it's like the the
uh the analogy I give him poker it's
like if you've got 100 million dollars
and some guy in poker says I'll give you
ten to one odds and I'll flip you a
quarter for that [__] 100 million
dollars so I'll give you a billion
dollars if you win or if you lose you go
broke you never take that flip like
anybody takes that flip so [__] idiot
and most times in life you're not
getting ten to one odds on your [__]
money so like once you get to a certain
level of wealth like you shouldn't be
taking big risks with your money you
know there's a lot of ways to have
possible home runs you know with like
some seed capital and a startup or
whatever where you're not risking like
all your [__] money so like I think a
lot of you people just think about it
wrong you know and they take risks
unnecessarily Hustler Academy over here
seriously yeah well it's important like
because you have to understand like the
incremental difference between having
700 million and having a billion is not
much but like you know or you know or
500 million to 700 it's like your life
doesn't change that much but like when
you start going the other way your life
starts changing you start work I mean
depending on like how spread out you are
because a lot of these guys are spread
out like I mean I own a plane I pay
three million dollars a year just for my
[__] plane you know so like people
have like you know nuts you know what I
mean like there's like costs that you
have to cover you got five houses you
got I mean I got 27 staff members you
know what I mean Floyd's got 360 people
on the payroll so it's like it depends
on like how big your operation is but
like as you get more wealth and as you
get more properties you have to have
people take care of the properties all
this [__] right so like it scales and so
I I don't know it's probably [__]
long wouldn't answer no I love it
because yeah it's epic dude thank you
for that it's epic and I'm asking
because like I've always had this idea
of like it's it's all perception and so
like I always wanted to write a book
Anonymous and then have like I would ask
you hey give me a one pager of what your
idea about money is and then you would
write a page about it it wouldn't even
be what your name is but at the bottom
would be what your net net worth was and
then the next person said you get like a
poor person you get a rich person you
get all different variating degrees of
it because some people are like man
money's the root of all evil it's this
is that it's like well they probably
don't have money or is that accurate I
mean so I've got different theories on
that too I mean basically the way I look
at it is you know a lot of people equate
money to happiness and it's not it's
more freedom
um and I think money brings happiness
and pleasure as you go up but what
people don't understand is like if you
once you have basic needs met you don't
get incremental happiness for more money
you do for a short period of time like
if you're a hundred thousand dollar a
year guy and I bump you to 200 000
you're going to be happy be but that's
not gonna last you're gonna get used to
200 000 I mean stripper mentality right
like a stripper makes ten thousand
dollars she spends ten thousand dollars
and now all of a sudden her Baseline
which she's used to which she's you know
it like the Baseline doesn't bring you
happiness right a baseline is zero you
can go up to ten you can go down to
negative ten but let's just set that
this is the Baseline is zero or you want
to set a baseline of five and the top is
ten and the bottom zero whatever the
point is wherever you are in your bass
line that doesn't bring you happiness my
problem is you know on a lot of rich
people their Baseline is a [__] 10.
so like there's nothing that I buy that
brings me happiness I bought a Ferrari I
wasn't happy for more than 24 hours to
put 100 miles on the [__] thing in a
year and got rid of it you know like I
just didn't care but when I was younger
that would have brought me to a [__]
ten the difference was my Baseline when
I was younger was a [__] three or
four you know when I was in the military
it's probably a [__] one you know
what I mean like making 860 bucks a
month so like depending on where your
Baseline is you have a lot more you know
leeway to go up and if you're making 800
sixty dollars a [__] month you don't
really have very far to [__] go down
so the thing is like when you get used
to a high level of wealth and now like
every car that you drive is a you know
[__] Mercedes or a rolls or whatever
the [__] ever then like when you go and
rent a car from Hertz it's always a
[__] let down you know if like you're
staying in a [__] you know 30 40
million dollar house and you go out and
you rent a house it better be a pretty
[__] baller house or it's going to be
a letdown like when I travel I got to
bring all my staff members of chefs
assistants [__] all this [__] you
know so that I can like semi maintain
the like what I'm accustomed to or else
it's kind of a letdown like you know so
it's you know it sounds cool and
whatever but sometimes like you know
it's a blessing and a curse you know
when you're used to this level yeah then
all these things are let down so it's
like that's why I think a lot of like
rich people are unhappy is because you
know like a normal guy look at a rich
guy and be like oh well this
motherfucker's driving a Lamborghini
he's got the hot [__] he's you know
eating the [__] good steak like how
could he not be happy because to the him
if he were to step into those shoes that
would immediately make him happy but
this guy's used all that [__] so when
this guy doesn't get a perfect steak or
his [__] [__] is an eight instead of
a ten he's like what the [__] you know
and so yeah and most people look at that
and be like oh that dude's
unappreciative or he you know like you
know but no he's just used to that [__]
you know it's like he's had that for so
long that that's what he's used to you
know and so I think perception is the
big thing that what I want to do when I
become billionaire is go work at Walmart
for three months and have like a full
reset not Walmart I probably work
construction but like whatever the [__]
it is like a hundred thousand dollar a
year job basic needs met but like a
massive [__] like change in life
right and then you get used to that just
like when I got out of boot camp man I
was like happy to go to [__] you know
Outback Steakhouse that was a 10 for me
you know getting getting eight hours of
sleep was a [__] ten you know
there's like a lot of things where it's
like after boot camp man like basic [__]
like somebody not Talent screaming at me
all [__] day was nice you know
what I mean like so it's all perspective
you get out of a concentration camp
you're gonna be [__] happy about a
lot of [__] you know so it's like a lot
of these people [__] at their [__]
life sucks and this and that but it's
like it's all relative like if you're
used to you know shitty life and a lot
of things are going to give you these
pleasure spikes I can't get pleasure
spikes anymore I feel like a high
[__] whatever you know I mean I get a
badass car it's whatever you know what I
mean like I eat a great meal satisfies
me you know what I mean but I'm like I'm
not getting those pleasure spikes and
for a guy that like has been seeking
pleasure for so long it's kind of shitty
and I compared it in the book it's like
being a drug addict you know it's like
you take you take a perk you know being
a pleasure Seeker is like being a drug
addict you take a Percocet makes you
feel good you know now two weeks later
you gotta take two Percocets to get the
same feeling three weeks later you're
taking three four five then eventually
you're taking them just to not feel like
[__] you don't get high anymore same
thing with pleasure what gets you high
now big hands of poker no I mean there's
just not a lot you know what I mean so
so really the answer is you got to like
focus on happiness and not pleasure
because pleasure is like fleeting and
pleasure is one of those things where
it's like it's a black hole you know so
what makes you happy
oh [__] surfing doing mushrooms hanging
with my friends and I mean like this
[__] that doesn't cost money to be
honest with you you know it's kind of
funny but like yeah the stuff that like
you really will get happiness from I
know it's like cliche but doesn't
[__] cause money do we try I gotta
add [__] all the money you know what
I mean I've done all the [__] like you
don't even [__] but it's you know the
stuff that doesn't really cost money the
[__] that makes me happy and so do you
like shopping on Amazon I do and good
news is Stevo's butt wipes for your butt
hole are available on Amazon and if you
want a real bundle of a deal you can get
Stevo's hot sauce for your butthole plus
Stephen's butthole destroyer and Stevo's
butt wipes for your butthole it's the
butthole bundle available on Amazon
right now
yeah dude